i think it was patty maroon that really
kind of like spread it among all the
players somebody was just playing one of
my songs and then they started digging
gravy train that song kind of became
like their victory celebration song yeah
the first time that they won i was there
at the game i went over to hang out with
all them afterwards i drink out of the
stanley cup that night posted a video of
it there were people like commenting
like kind of pissed off about it like
some like gatekeeper hockey fans that
were like yeah they let me do it i
really thought about it now that you say
it i mean like if i could give a pep
talk in like uh in the locker room epic
speech before before a real big game or
something there was there was one moment
they had me do like the big announcement
thing over for the whole stadium where
that they said be the thunder they had
me do that and it's be the thunder and
this guy was like all right you got this
to be the thunder and i like prepped it
like three times so i beat the thunder
and i went up and i was like bring that
thunder and i like i said dude i got two
of the words wrong out of three man a
lot of people like know of hockey but
haven't been to a game but once you go
it's the best sport to watch live i
think it's the most hiked sport by far